is a very famous person so he's just
like in the media everyone is in his
business every guy most person of guys
out there when you have money to just
[__] around sorry they just yeah they
just F around even broke guys do it yeah
it's like does Galaxy actually call to
those apartments they had a choice to
say no but he's spending money on them a
lot of girls go for that do you know
what I mean like so that does not make
him a bad person it's just because he's
famous then people are like in his
business all this this like do you know
what I mean and does he chase women or
do the women chase them have you ever
seen a very like attractive successful
guy the women come to them they don't
have to do [__] like have you seen like
a professional athletes there are women
that buy hotels at every game trying to
get them to cheat on their wives that is
their full goal there's like it'll be
like the hottest 22 year olds you've
ever seen in your life sitting on the
sideline saying we're down for a three
like this is the thing that the guys get
thrown at them every single home